I quit my job again hey what's new
[Music]
very
hey y'all so it's been a while since I
joined this vlog camera on because my
battery died and I realized that I left
my battery charger in Japan so my
parents shipped it to me and I finally
got it and it's here um I'm about to eat
some lunch and then hopefully do some
things in the afternoon we'll see
[Music]
I should tell you what I'm eating for
lunch so
oh hi caught you hey here's my
neighbor's dog that we're watching for
the day
hi here so I just made some ginger uh
dong which is just chicken broth Otzi
you like a Japanese soup broth and then
ginger and green onions and then this
over here is leftover nikujaga which is
meat and potatoes basically except
there's only meat and carrots left
that's just leftovers very tasty
[Music]
Hey Wow
oh that's not you can't like that
okay all right we're back from the
optometrist well I did get worse
what are you doing Cole what are you
doing you trying to snuggle Oh cutie ha
ha ha um see ya my eyes did get worse
and that's to be expected because it
always gets worse a little bit over over
the years and my doctor just said it's
just because I spend so much time on the
computer so using computer glasses is
something she definitely recommends I'm
gonna do that
so yeah you all might be wondering why
that footage was there from a week and a
half ago I quit my job again hey what's
new so I didn't really say this at all
on purpose where I was working but I was
working at Netflix so first time I've
ever worked at a faing company and I was
there for a year and two months ish and
it was great I really enjoyed my time
there I had an awesome team an amazing
manager but I left and the reason being
because I needed some time I needed to
take a break I think I feel like I've
just been kind of go go go for the last
two issues actually more than that three
and a half years and I know that doesn't
seem very long but also tech moves very
fast and I wanted some time in space to
figure out where I wanted to take my
career next because in a lot of ways I
feel like I've reached a check point in
my career as an iOS engineer and Netflix
they don't they rarely promote people
into management positions and also I was
doing iOS development and I realized a
little bit that not everybody needs a
nap
and I definitely like kind of burrowed
myself into a niche in terms of software
development which I did on purpose and
I'm glad that I did but where I wanted
to go next was a complete blank in my
mind not to mention just like I wanted
also some time to figure out like hey if
I wasn't gonna do software development
or if I had the time and space to figure
out what I
wanted to do what would it be as always
I've been doing a lot of introspection
about like what do I want in life and
where do I want to go for the first time
I was kind of like you know I don't know
I think my career thus far has been what
I imagined to be from college and it's
what I was working towards this whole
time but I'm realizing there's like a
lot of a lot more other things that I
want in life and things that like my
current job couldn't give me so yeah I
mean those things being things like
being able to work more flexibly hours
wise location wise being able to work on
different kinds of projects building on
certain skills that I wanted all the
while I wasn't feeling super fulfilled
at my job at Netflix and so in contrast
like I was feeling very fulfilled in
doing YouTube work so it was just kind
of this like just not working out it's
the the saying it chief kind of think
and so I left and I know that I'm in an
incredibly fortunate position to be able
to do so and so I did I took advantage
of that position and I did and what I'm
up to now is honestly I've been fun
employee for about a week and a half now
and I'm cut I'm just using this time to
heal
as I mentioned him I get ready for 2020
with a new video I'm gonna experiencing
lots of anxiety over the last three
months and I think that this is a really
good opportunity for me to keep
regaining that balance and figure out
what is the lifestyle that I want and
really think about where I want to go
next
this doesn't necessarily mean that I'm
like a full-time youtuber per se I think
I will keep making videos but I just
don't know whether this is what I want
to do the whole time and if so like how
do I want to do it so yeah I'm kind of
just keeping my options open being
open-minded maybe I'll do YouTube maybe
I'll do something completely different
maybe I'll start contracting freelancing
maybe I'll just get another iOS job who
knows it's the first time that I feel
like I can really make this decision for
me without any of the other
that I need to worry about so I'm gonna
do that I'm 27
this is a right time for a quarter life
crisis
so that's me now so yeah I've kind of
just been filling my time the last like
week and a half with chores and hanging
out with friends and relaxing and eating
good food and just chilling out honestly
which has been so good from my body it's
been very very good so that's the scoop
on why I left and where I even was it
was really great I really liked working
at Netflix and I'm so glad to have had
the opportunity to do that and work with
the amazing people that I did it just it
just didn't work out like it was kind of
like a breakup it just wasn't working
out and that's ultimately my decision
and I'll take responsibility for it but
I did grow a lot as a person and I'll
take those lessons with me and I feel
nothing but gratitude towards all of
that for the last year and a half so all
good things onward and upwards you know
I I think I'm hungry now and I kind of
want to eat something cuz it's new so
let's let's make lunch okay let's let's
move on from this heavy topic and eat
something yeah let's do that okay
so I kind of want to fill in my vlogs in
both Japanese and English so Jeff and
when I speak Japanese will be subtitles
below but psyching Kenan I need a visa
either a moment on this kiddo
sorry no naka no it's your God it took
me so long you know we see it in oh god
yes crab miso ramen design is killing in
toto inspire holiday Ryoka tomo TechSoup
team hasta que cuando Kino Nikita better
know one you do cricketer mean eatery
Augustana yes to put a bit in your mouth
oh hey mate isoquant me to see your bar
- yeah I know
don't know me tonight cutter ah well yes
I hak Tsai toka toka tonic oh hey -
internet care there's not at all
well Nick Nick took our singing it took
our daughter Agora soup
no drama diva Oh me so toka on the scale
oh good on me so - zoom it I know yet
there yeah oh you idiot a new so called
on Akane man we did the story oh you
didn't miss you
there's no hanging onsen tamago Medina
took the meters just took the supply
Stanzione yeah it also no in Santo Tommy
no it's soup not open honest a nice car
sorry oh I'm no good I get it yeah they
towed a car talking me or you or
needed this OCO karim no no you didn't
schedule creo buys them me Chuck Joey
see this
you took choices catecholamines savage I
saw ho paura annually No
[Music]